out-of-the-box was a popular children's
show that aired from 1998 to 2004 the
hosts Tony and Vivian sang and made
crafts inside of an imaginary house made
entirely out of cardboard we caught up
with them 20 years after the first
episode air people always ask me what
what sort of what am I so my strongest
memories from the show what some of my
favorite episodes and really they're all
wonderful in their own ways but what I
really remember is this laughter so many
times there would be opportunities where
it was just her it would just be her
scene and we'd go behind and watch the
monitors while she was doing her scene
and I was just always just in awe of her
she's a magnificent vocalist and and
person and I loved it it was great
working with him
it's I wouldn't trade it for the world
he was so supportive I always felt like
he had my back we had a great connection
you know the producers wanted us all to
use our real names like so all the kids
their real names you know and and I love
it cuz you can watch like the first
season they'll call me Vivian and then
all of a sudden like second season
they'll be like this being able to call
each other by our real names you know
Tony and I the relationship you see on
TV is our relationship then I get all
the credit because we were the ones in
front of the camera but what you didn't
see is the 75 other people who worked
behind the camera to present this show
that millions of people actually ended
up loving all these years we shot in a
story yet actually the same place right
next to bear in the big blue house and
right above Sesame Street which was
bright mind-blowing because growing up
Sesame Street was much I am Tony and I
went all day but the kids are required
by law to go to school for half a day so
we did three hours in the morning and
then three hours in
afternoon basically in like a little
over a week we'd have two episodes I've
been in the arts my entire life this
actually speaks to I think one of the
reasons I was cast because they were
looking for someone who was a musician
who was primarily a prick who could play
percussion and specialize in junk
percussion and I have I've had that
experience because I was in the original
American cast of stomp
even before stop I worked as a session
and touring musician and I played with
Billy Squier and Cyndi Lauper and tell
Mariah Carey and now of course to this
audience those names may not mean that
much but you know that was a while ago
one of the biggest reasons for the
show's popularity was this diverse cast
I was excited to represent because I
didn't realize it I don't think at the
time at the time I was just super super
excited to be doing it you know but it
was kind of I think after the fact that
it started you know airing that when I
would meet people just you know out in
public they would ask me are you for
looking up it was cool you know because
it was important to them I think it was
very important because it's reflective
of our world and you know I'm a native
New Yorker so you know that's what's all
our diversity is all around us here's
what Tony and Vivian are up to today I'm
putting the finishing touches on some
new music that I'll release this year of
just going over some artwork and
discussing storyboards for videos and
all that stuff so I'm really excited
about that so stay tuned there's gonna
be some new music coming out really soon
so I'm a mom that is my life and I love
it love it love it love it I love my
daughter I love my husband I love being
a teacher because that's mainly what I
do now um I'm a voice and piano teacher
I music direct for several colleges
children's theaters high schools see
when I was growing up I always knew I
was gonna do something with music and I
was gonna do
with children because those were my two
loves I'm I've been really touched and
honored because a lot of you know the
generation that grew up with box that
the the the kids and their parents have
reached out and expressed online and in
person how much the shows meant to them
goodbye for now until we meet again
goodbye for now until we meet again
[Music]